it's the next generation of gaming baby
which means 4k resolutions
3d audio immersion and late romantic
nights with your new best friends
the playstation 5 and xbox series x or s
and you'll need to treat them right
which means
making sure you've got the right tv
sound bars capture cards and snuggies
ready
this is kurt and let's get you set up
for the next generation of gaming
first up tvs whether you're going with
the playstation 5 or the xbox series
consoles both of them are putting out 4k
resolutions and are capable of pushing
120 frames per second so there are some
important factors to consider
when getting a tv to get the most out of
your new consoles
here's the basics is it 4k does it
support 120 hertz
and if so does it have an hdmi 2.1
port most games at the moment support 60
frames per second
but we'll likely be seeing a lot more at
120 over this new generation
and in order to actually make use of
that refresh rate properly at 4k
the tv will need to support hdmi 2.1
hdmi 2.1 cables put out 48 gigabytes per
second of information
which makes 4k and 120 frames per second
possible on supported tvs i won't get
into that too much
here but we have another video all about
it how it differs from 2.0 and why it's
important to the next gen
of gaming check it out in the
description below or in the suggested
corner in the top right
as for a tv that checks all the boxes we
suggest the lg
cx oled 4k tv
delivers on all fronts and features an
oled
panel to make these colors pop other
runner-ups are the samsung q8t
qled tv and the sony x900h
now it's important to note you'll still
be able to play the new consoles on tvs
that don't have these exact specs
and it'll still be great just keep in
mind that looking for these tvs will
allow you to get the absolute most
out of your new children i mean consoles
we have more information on some of that
stuff in an article on our site too
you know where to find it below in the
description
pretty graphics pixels and triangles
aren't the only things to get excited
about
sound is also taking a big leap around
you
with 3d audio but there's a few key
differences to keep in mind between both
the ps5 and the xbox series x
let's start with playstation the ps5 is
all about its tempest
3d audio tech however for the ps5 3d
audio will not be supported through
tv speakers and surround sound systems
at launch
making headphone audio as playstation
architect mark cerny put it
the current gold standard for 3d audio
it is coming eventually though
for headphones there is the pulse 3d
wireless headset which has been
engineered
to fully show off the ps5's audio
capabilities
some developers are specifically
designing their sound to make the most
of the console's new audio opportunities
such as capcom for resident evil village
thankfully you don't need the pulse
headset to get that rich immersive sound
experience
a broad range of headphones will work
and you'll need to plug them in the ps5
via usb
or into the dual sensor's 3.5 millimeter
audio jack
sony is working to eventually bring its
3d audio to tv speakers and surround
sound system so when that day comes
we suggest taking a look at dolby atmos
supported sound bars
xbox series x already supports dolby
atmos tech
so that way you can't go wrong with
either console especially if you get
both
that said the xbox series x also
features native 3d sound support with
dts x and as just mentioned
dolby atmos in fact at this very moment
dts x is actually supported with the
xbox one with games like gears 5
resident evil 2 final fantasy xv and a
bunch of others taking full advantage of
it
so to wrap it up just make sure that
whatever sound bar you're getting it
supports dolby atmos
ones like the sennheiser mbo or the sony
ht
st5000 in the case that having a
surround system or sound bar isn't a big
concern to you
the lg cx tv mentioned earlier has dolby
atmos support as well making it really
the
all-in-one gaming tv package at the
moment
since these chunkers are putting out a
4k you may want to upgrade to a capture
card that supports 4k
if you're looking to put your clips on
youtube to show all your friends
the elgato 4k 60s plus as you'd probably
guess from its name
captures gameplay at 4k up to 60 frames
per second
however it doesn't have 120 fps
pass-through so
just keep that in mind another runner-up
is the elgato hd60s plus
this little dude is only capable of
capturing 1080p60
however it can pass through a 4k60
signal
so if capturing of the full resolution
isn't a priority this is a solid second
option
another option is the avermedia live
gamer ultra there's also capture cards
that go internally into your pc like the
4k
live gamers which supports hdr capture
and passthrough
or the elgato 4k60 pro and if you're
already a streamer or considering
getting into it you guessed it we have
an article on some of the best gear to
get started with
from a selection of mics and webcams you
can find it below
and lastly snuggle up we're heading into
chili season so
grab yourself some hot cocoa a weighted
blanket or a heavy cat if you have one
with those uh slipper socks with the
rubber gripping on the bottom they're
great
you won't regret it oh and drink water
make sure to check out the description
for links to other game spot videos and
articles mentioned in this video
good luck out there and here's to many
lovely nights and killing werewolves or
backtracking to reclaim your lost souls
for more on the past
present and future of gaming keep your
eyes on gamespot and while you're at it
check out generation next it's the show
about
next generation consoles alright i'm
kurt thanks again
be well
you